I'm Oceanic welcome to Baywatch our team
is the elite of the elite
but the heart soul of this very Beach
come on feed make my patches a little
bigger and don't cover up my front bump
you got it huge dick big dick we're
staring into the abyss here it's up to
us restore the Baywatch brand hey One
Direction you here for the qualifiers
I'm Matt Brody I don't have to try out
I've got two gold medals training begins
at 600
[Applause]
what is it that you think we do here
prevent people from getting sunburned
occasionally stop them from drowning I
can't see your finger this is the guy
you think it's a good PR opportunity for
us look I get it being sasquatch I'm
fast
[ __ ] touch him in shock
drugs murder dead body on our Beach and
it all started once she took over some
people are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
that's best the truth is one of you will
probably die what no the only one that
thinks this is clearly a job for the
police
Thank You blue eyed demon you got one
job make sure swim happy white people
don't drown so I did she always look
like she's running in slo-mo she's the
reason I believe in God
we gotta go undercover
yeah undercover yeah little to
undercover
Jason Bourne ain't got [ __ ] on me
why are we in the morgue you got to get
some hard evidence what's coming over
your down shall we hide we're empty why
did you pick that drawer sub-industry
it's just a little dead man's fact
necrotic liquid fat then will you stop
being a baby
you
you